yeah man-eater has turned my xbox one
off
twice i guess the sharks are in the
system
i got the overheat issue that people
have been reporting
let's try again i hope this works i
just want to be a shock i got a lot of
pent-up rage and anger right now
and sadness which i guess sharks maybe
relate to i would just like
to let that out in shock form please
work
also it's scary having consoles crash in
front of me i'd prefer if that didn't
happen
can i skip the cutscene let's try
that might work
i hope i really hope come on buddy come
on buddy
okay this seems like a good call man
this is an adult [ __ ] fast fierce
and armed quite literally
she has a little to fear here in the
gulf please don't crash
i need this so bad okay yeah what up
i don't it's brilliant okay it is it is
weird
controller marvel confidently moves
sweet baby i don't want to eat the
turtles i really don't want to eat the
turtles
what do you think i'm some kind of
sociopath
no yeah here you go hey bud oh [ __ ]
really uncoordinated shock i don't want
to know about it oh
oh okay good good good good good
i mean nothing's not going to attack me
i could eat it but it's fine who cares
whatever
i did it accidentally turns out aiming
is difficult
for shock
not a coordinated shark oh for context
because we skipped the cutscene that
little
stabby thing is in me because i had a
fight with uh the humans and i believe
well maybe that's the next cutscene
um big bad human guy wanted me to be
recognizable i think
so i got like a little i don't know
attacked [ __ ] coming out
i'm not [ __ ] with the turtle i'm
sorry you can you can get [ __ ] slapped
i don't care the turtles are safe
sweet exhibiting behavior more common to
a thresher
this this shark is so uncoordinated
what are you throwing yourself with
nothing for bro swim to the surface at
normal speed to enter knifing knifing
allows you to skim the surface of the
water
while you stalk your prey
yeah let's knife ah
beautiful it's funny the most recent
game i finished was abzu and now i play
this
here we go look at him go
we can jump into the air from a knife
okay
the bull performs an acrobatic word look
at this
look at that mouth look at all those
it's really nice having this narrated by
cyril figgis
the bull's speed is astounding for a
large movie
just such a terrible aim yeah no
no come on uh it's you that i want yeah
oh well
i was going for the grouper but i got
the mahi-mahi or whatever that is
wait i have to breach the surface oh
okay yeah sure
a breaching shark is a rare and calorie
intensive spectacle
i've actually never seen a breaching
shark is that a thing that sharks even
do
cereal figgis i don't know if that's a
real thing that happens
what did like has anyone seen a shark do
that
i don't know if they do sick acrobatics
i'm not a shock person
i can't tell you for sure but i'm not
sure that sick acrobatics is on the list
of things that sharks do
okay oh no not a tunnel not a turtle
we're just not gonna i don't know
grouper and then lb to whip shot
it'll just let's be in its tail with
whip-like precision
a little [ __ ] no i can't do that
rt i say you
i'm sorry i am shocked sometimes cannot
be helped
no i don't really want her to seal
either oh just the moral conundrum of
being a shark
this is not working i'm doing something
wrong
it just really challenges your morals
you know to be able to eat
shocks and turtles and also just not
give a [ __ ] about fish
which is on me [ __ ]
can you imagine watching a shark do this
all the other fish are like
is he drunk what is this guy doing
you can customize the shock i'm just not
at that point yet but you absolutely can
get
back to your little if i accidentally
kill a turtle i'm going to cry
that's the truth get back here
stupid neon idiot
[ __ ] [ __ ] this stupid uncoordinated
shock
you look so dumb i guess i did it
i don't even really know how
i will take that 20g thank you that's a
good time for me
kill the beachgoers
okay and i'm gonna do it in style
look at me go y'all can you imagine
seeing a shark
heading towards you on the beach doing
this
that's not a good time you don't want to
be anywhere in this water
that shark is out for blood
oh there it goes again
i was so excited you know
i was i was gonna
tail whip or whatever it was called a
human
here i am no um i guess i can't play
this game
that's a huge bummer i was excited about
this i needed this today
and i guess i just can't do it
maybe it was going to cue up a cutscene
again and that's what breaks the game i
don't know
if ronan who's watching and it's not
aware i guess uh man eater
has some pretty significant issues where
it will crash your xbox and do this
when you turn it back on turn back on
all right buddy come on
come on and then we do the thing where
the green screen gets all weird cause
the
green light is shining on my face and i
love that for me
i am become the green i'm inside the
matrix
don't worry about it it's not a big deal
hmm now it's taking a really long time
to turn on
please be okay okay this is what happens
when you try to play man-eater
on xbox one this xbox console is
designed to automatically shut down to
protect it from insufficient ventilation
like other electronic devices the xbox
console requires proper ventilation
which i have it is not a ventilation or
heating issue
whatsoever it is a bug with this game
which is the weirdest [ __ ] like just
so unexpected i didn't even really know
that that can happen
so i guess i just can't play it um until
they patch it
looks like a lot of people have had the
problem and i don't want to keep trying
because i feel like this is the
equivalent of just pulling the power
plug
it is just hard turning the console off
which obviously
can't be good for it i don't want to
screw up my hardware just for my shock
dreams
um as much as i really would have liked
to have a bit of shock
it's really sad that i caught but yeah
here we are huge bummer and especially
for the launch of this game i really
would have liked to have played it
and given it a shout out it's it's a
it's a smaller team and they made
something that's like
pretty fun and cool that we just can't
play
echo the dolphin wouldn't have done me
dirty like this no hate to the team
of course i'm sure they don't they don't
want this to be happening but um
yeah everyone on reddit is saying the
same thing once again to combat with the
hunter boats in the tutorial my xbox one
x crashes
tripwire is the developer they did say
may need a known issues psa xbox one
overheating we are aware that some xbox
one x users
are having an overheat shutdown message
i did that wrong overheat shutdown
message and are working with microsoft
to address this issue we are also aware
that a set of ps4 players are reporting
something similar
and also investigating so there you go
and there are progress and save issues
as well
the issue with not being able to 100 it
and some frame rate losses on ps4
massive bomber i really hope that they
can get this fixed um
because i really wanted to really wanted
to support this game
i did really try um all right
well i guess i'm gonna call that ben i
told my friends i would be playing sea
of thieves with them at eight so
i guess i'll just go cry in the meantime
um but for everyone who didn't know
we are uh myself
crank gameplays robin ninja and
jacksepticeye are streaming
tomorrow to raise money for causes
related
to um well basically everything that's
happening in minnesota right now not not
necessarily just one specific thing but
uh yeah oh we'll be live at 1 pm pt
if you would like to join us raise some
money have some fun we're gonna be
playing minecraft dungeons it should be
a good time i look forward to it
and unfortunately that is where i'm
gonna have to end the stream
which is a huge bummer yeah sorry
everyone i will see you guys tomorrow
though i don't imagine that we're gonna
have any
goddamn crash issues with um minecraft
dungeons though ross has had a really
tough time downloading the game
alright see you guys thank you